>>> PRAISE FOR QUEEN ELIZABETH,
POURING IN FROM ACROSS THE GLOBE
FOLLOWING HER REIGN.
CELEBRITIES AND OTHERS WHICH THE
COMMONWEALTH NATION.
>> FLAGS FLYING HALF-STAFF IN
PLACES LIKE THE BAHAMAS, THE
QUEEN VISITED MOST RECENTLY IN
1994.
LISTEN TO HOW ONE WOMAN THERE
WILL REMEMBER THE QUEEN.
>> SHE'S EVERYBODY'S MOTHER.
SHE'S ONE OF THE MOST
OUTSTANDING PERSONS AND WOMEN IN
MY LIFETIME.
>> CNN INTERNATIONAL ANCHOR
JOINING US NOW.
ZANE, DISSONANCE BECAUSE OF THE
RESERVE REFERENCE, SOME PERSONAL
AND AWARENESS OF BRITAIN'S
HISTORY, SOME OF WHICH LIVES ON
IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF WHICH
THERE IS REAL OPPOSITION AND
UPSET.
LARRY WAS DISCUSSING THAT
EARLIER.
YOU'RE FROM A NIGERIAN FAMILY.
GREW UP IN THE UK.
I WONDER HOW YOU PERSONALLY VIEW
THAT?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT A LOT OF BLACK
PEOPLE WHO ARE BRITISH BY BIRTH
AND WHO HAVE AFRICAN ANCESTRY,
THE RELATIONSHIP THAT A LOT OF
US HAVE WITH THE ROYAL FAMILY
IS -- YOU WATCHED THE ROYALS ARE
THE PINNACLE OF BRITISH HIGH
SOCIETY.
YOU ARE TAUGHT RESPECT AND
RESERVE REFERENCE FOR EVERYTHING
THAT THE CROWN AND THE SCEPTER
STAND FOR AND ALSO, BY THE WAY,
MY OWN PERSONAL SITUATION.
IF YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF
IMMIGRANTS, GREW UP IN THE UK
YOU CRAVE A SENSE OF BECOMING
AND UNDERSTANDING THE MONARCHY
IS WHAT UNITED STATES THE
NATION.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THOUGH,
YOU'RE ALSO AWARE, TAUGHT IN
SCHOOL, LEARN ON YOUR OWN, A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE SORT
OF DARKER HISTORY OF
COLONIALISM.
>> YEAH.
>> THE BRITISH EMPIRE WAS PART
OF THE GREATEST COLONIAL
EXPERIMENT THE WORLD HAS EVER
KNOWN, AND YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
COLONIALISM ACTUALLY INVOLVES,
JIM.
IT IS UGLY BUSINESS.
>> YEAH.
>> THE BUSINESS OF SUBJUGATING
PEOPLE BY FORCE IS A BRUTAL ONE.
I GREW UP WITH STORIES OF, YOU
KNOW, VILLAGES IN NIGERIA BEING
BURNED.
YOU KNOW?
PRECIOUS ARTIFACTS LOOTED.
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF PEOPLE DIEING
THROUGH THAT ENTIRE PROCESS.
I THINK THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
QUEEN ELIZABETH SPECIFICALLY,
THERE IS AN UNDERSTANDING AND AN
AWARENESS SHE ASCENDED TO THE
THRONE IN 1952 AND WAS MUCH MORE
INVOLVED AND SORT OF, SHE
OVERSAW MUCH MORE THE SORT OF
BREAKDOWN OF THE BRITISH EMPIRE
AND NOT THE BUILDING OF IT.
AND I THINK THAT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT TO SORT OF TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION.
SHE HASN'T FOUGHT CHANGE AS MUCH
AS SHE COULD HAVE.
SO I THINK IF THERE IS THIS SORT
OF LINGERS SENSE OF RESENTMENT
BY SOME PEOPLE OF COLOR.
OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T GENERALIZE
MANY WHO, TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THE UK IF THERE IS SOME
RESENTMENT I THINK IT IS TOWARDS
THE MONARCHY, NOT NECESSARILYDI.
THE MONARCHY VERSUS THE QUEEN.
>> SUCH A HELPFUL EXPLANATION
AND IMPORTANT DISTINCTION.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT LARRY
REPORTED ON LAST HOUR THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT IS, REAL
ANGER AMONGST SOME SHE DID NOT
APPALL THE ACTIONS OF THE EMPIRE
BUILDING, BUT THE NEW MONARCH
CAN.
THERE ARE THINGS NOW.
THE QUESTION, WHAT WILL KING
CHARLES DO, AND WHAT MAY BE SAID
THAT WASN'T SAID?
>> I THINK IN THE NEW REIGN
YOU'LL SEE WHETHER THIS SORT OF
COMMONWEALTH EXPERIMENT DEFINES
THE UNITED KINGDOM.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, BUT YOU SAW LAST YEAR
BARBADOS, FOR EXAMPLE, REMOVING
OF THE QUEEN AS HEAD OF STATE.
SEEING GROWING CALLS,
REPUBLICANISM IN VARIOUS
COMMONWEALTH NATIONS ESPECIALLY
CARIBBEAN.
THIS IDEA THERE IS NOW AN
UNDERSTANDING HOW MUCH MONEY THE
ROYAL FAMILY MAY HAVE MADE FROM
SLAVERY.
THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN
COLONIALISM, AND THERE ARE CALLS
FOR REPARATIONS.
RIGHT?
AND EVEN IF THE REPARATIONS ARE
UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN, YOU SORT OF
DO GET THE SENSE THAT IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THERE'S BEEN NO
APOLOGY.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE REALLY TAKE
ISSUE WITH AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
>> AS YOU KNOW, REPUBLICAN
MOVEMENTS IN AUSTRALIA AS WELL.
NORTHERN IRELAND.
RIGHT?
DOES THAT LEAVE